你知道
我是
这是什么东西
毛笔
笔
现在特别流行为的
类似毛笔
这是软笔
这种笔
我还以为写成的能够有一块金条呢
哈哈哈
你不要说这边
我还觉得我穿多了
结果我一看你
好像穿得比我还厚
我昨天回来的
我看那些
今天的气温好像是挺低的
就是特意换了一样厚衣
我要一个冰的
在山崖的时候
有时候有活动的话
一天能喝三杯冰美食
晚上不会睡不着吗
老师
因为不喝也睡不着
啊这样啊
那我就放心了
喝也睡不着
那还不如喝冷的
是吧
那我们就是
先去院子里边转转
小院子
叫金台园
特别清
为什么清建长吗
当年我们在鲁迅文学院
一带要进城
我们坐公交车
总是经过人民日报的大门口
啊就要金台啊
所谓的金台路就是这个金台
因为当年严金八经
有一些叫金台西兆
那我们一边一个吧
对一边一个吧
老师
等一下
我换一个手
这是中国文学的
有我们的作品吗
必须有
那必须有
真太有了
人民日报社
竟然没有余华的书
这不太
我的书都被借走了
对 这才有
也没
也没都被借走
这个版本我还从来没看到
你们收藏了几十万特殊
是吧
对
这个历史有久
还可以看看我们这都是请
报社有一些老师
画的一些文学家呀
旁边还画了那个
石切成老师的故居
哦 他的眼的时候的那个
你老没去过
窑洞
清平湾的时候
啊
嗯
窑洞
我没去过他的那个清平湾
给您看一眼
这是您
你几岁
一会我会展示一个这个
团结壶的那个
那个时候我应该三十多
三十一
对
这张真的很像电影明星
是不是
莫娅老师
就就是
这张好像电影明星
这张照片太有名了
这张照片
我看看莫燕那张
我这肯定不行了
这个是你跟她出现的时候
那个时候你在高密的拍的吧
长桥部队的那个汤库里
最后有一个部分是
我们叫快问快答
这个全是我们争集的
那个两万个问题里的
两万个问题
真是够多了
我还以为你们就
几十个留言呢
两万多留言
还在增加
有没有人知道
微信公众号的粉丝
六千三百的
哦 那么多
那莫燕 你在
你那个公号有多少粉丝
我呢 没多少粉丝
也就是几万个粉丝
不到六千万粉丝
我要六千万粉丝
你还敢惹我
我发那个粉丝
我一人一句话
就把你骂过来
两万个问题点赞第一
差不多九千个人点赞
就说帮我们问问
焦虑了怎么办
挺急的
真的挺急的
我天天想找人问问这个问题
他来问我
我问谁去
对 您就可以这么答
你现在不要回答
好好好
我把那些好话留着
对对对
人民日报新媒体的网友们
大家好
我是人民日报记者李娜
前几天
我在这个夜读来信的栏目
我发了一条征集
我说马上要采访
莫言和余华了
在线等挺急的
向大家征集
想我问两位老师的问题
我们收到的这个问题的数量
是非常惊人
我们收到了两万多条问题
今天我就带着大家的
两万多个问题
来问一问
莫言老师
余华老师
请两位老师
跟我们的网友们打个招呼吧
我不是孟爷
这个好球的余华
好有传句
我们不仅是同事
两位老师
还是智友
还是室友
就我们最前门摆的这本
莫言老师不被大风吹到
里面就有一张
我的室友余华
我看看我这里面
有没有写了一个莫言的篇
有 这个写作课里
您谈了莫言老师的欢乐
对对对
所以我们精心挑选了
这两本书
两位的书里都谈了
对对对
莫言老师
这个最新的新作
我这个书里
就是余华的祖先了
新的
你那个
不被大风吹到里面
是原来清醒的
后来你改了个名字
那种
自由
也有
这个有些余华的祖先
二比一
这个书上热搜了
就是大家都想知道
莫言老师的那个书里写余华的祖先
写的是啥
我已经看过了
这个我这个事先
争求过余华的一点
我写了这么一篇小文章
准备收到极字里去
你看你同意发表
不同意发表
我给了他一个表情
就是一个大拇指
一个大拇指
所以我这个斗胆的
他发了
本来我想
你既然投意了
我得多加点佐料
是吧
后来想还是不行
还是给赵远搞发了
这个我
我们准备了两张
老师们年轻时候的照片
是不是你们
跟你们出见
是不是大概就是这个样子
看看
我们出见面的时候差不多
余华当时就是
比这个要漂亮一点
这个照片给他
这个是我已经毕业以后拍的
这个是不是你还在学校的时候拍的
不如这个就是上学之前
上学之前
这是1987年的时候
我在我们部队的汤库里面
写作的时候
拍了这么张照片
很有名的一张照片
这个摄影师
肖权
我的照片里面最著名的照片
就是这一张
黄洁虎公共机车下
夏雪
后来我儿子看到这个照片的时候
他非常惊讶
因为这个是你们采检的
他那个照片还要稍微大一点
团结枯那个时候这么黄凉
当年就是那么黄凉
还有电线
这张照片应该还是让我回忆起来
当时写作的这种艰苦的条件
这个是您就在写作
是不是
1987年
我当时正在写
1987年在写
写一个长篇小说
天堂算财之歌
这就是我们董参政治部
文化部的堂库
里面摆着很多的篮球
排球
电影放影的一些器材
我就在堂库里住
那没房子
堂库的
我的前面全是一堆篮球箱子
挪得很高
我那个床就在篮球中间
睡觉提一觉
那个箱子的篮球
绷绷的响
在后面的墙笔上
贴着旧报纸挂电线
本来我有一张照片
还是手里面拿了一个满头
拿了一颗大通
也是那个时候照的
1987年到现在
快四十年了
三十九年过去了
今天有一次您说
让余华老师给您证明
您年轻的时候是绣发
这个照片完全证明了
一头绣发
那时候是黑发三千张
确实是真照片
没戴假发套
这边还有两张
这两张是
这一张就是德国
因为我一看后面是德国国旗
否则还真想不起来
是在哪个国家
这是我们2009年去
法拉克福苏展前
在柏林
在柏林的时候
对
下面那张跟铁声寺在哪时候
这一张就是在
辽宁文学院
哦对对对
这是著名的辽宁文学院
这不是刘正云吗
对对对
这个是谁我忘记了
我忘了忘了
两个可能辽宁文学院
对对对
这就是
这是跟辽宁文学院的人合影吗
对
那个马元跑哪去了呢
马元那里面
这里面没有吧
没有没有没有
当时可能辽宁文学院的两个年轻人
对对对
88年
89年
旁边的刘正云
刘正云的小胡子是吧
根本看不出是刘正云
还有这个是您吗
对对对
站在余华老师身后
那是我
那是我SO
刚才也谈到两位老师
就是一起出国的那个事情
之前其实大家都知道
余华老师说的
啊我们几个去演讲
谈怎么走上文学之路的
我们几个都是瞎编的
对
那今天我们要不要正经的说一说
走上文学之路
是哪一个瞬间
让你们决定
我要成为一个小说家
我要开始以写作为生了
有这个瞬间吗
我想听听墨延的第三个版本
这个
你刚才说这个为什么要写作是吧
就是我们1998年是吧
98年1月份
我们是在巴黎过的春节
在巴黎过的春节
我们从意大利都零
本来是要坐火车
但是火车工人霸耕的
然后找了一个
在中国留过学的那个小伙子
叫马里克
我都忘了他
他开了一个很小的车
我只记得巴巴拉
拉着我余华王硕
巴巴拉
你想他那个小车
可能是一个很小的
非常急
就是那个菲亚特的那个小车
这个活动应该是在独灵
他一个大学里面搞的
是吧
有一个东方论团之类的
就是其中的其中的一个题目就是
我为什么要写作
大概
我们当时每个人说的
豆腐未必是真心话
当时那个年代说实话
就是大家都希望追求一种
演讲的幽默效果
希望能够让下面的听证哈哈一笑
所以我说的版本就是
我这个
像过上一天三段吃饺子的生活
那就要穿皮鞋了
皮鞋皮鞋
你最早版本是皮鞋
我说我有两个版本
一个就是为了买一双
闪神法令的皮鞋
买一块手表
再一个就是为了过上一天三段
吃饺子的生活
那现在让我说的话
那什么时候决定写作
什么时候决定当作家
这个确实是很难具体的
哪一天哪一个细节
但是有一点是肯定的
因为我们阅读
说在阅读的过程当中
产生了喜多的欲望
读的越多就能欲望越强烈
读的越多对文学的热爱越加深一点
就在阅读的过程当中
产生了想当作家的愿望
那么这个有没有功利心肯定是有的
那么这个功利心刚才我说的
吃饺子呀
穿皮鞋呀带手表都不排除
因为它都是一个年轻人
这种爱好虚荣
爱美之心人人都有
当然也有鼻子了
高大上的理想和愿望也都有
我们也不仅仅为了吃来写作
首先心里面还有对小说这种热爱
对文学这种痴迷
那一步排除
想通过写作改变你的命运
这样一种比较世俗的动力
当然也有高大上了
我要用我的笔说书写心中的情感
要用我的笔
要用我的文章来描述现实生活
等等
这是非常标准的一个办法
应该是今后不会再改了
他的话你们不要太相信
今后不会再改
一个月以后就改了
对
其实那个是这样的
当时其实我们去都临之前
我们也没有事前商量
我们大家都拿到一个题目
就是我为什么写作
是吗
都是这么一个题目
要我们事前写完以后
就是人家要翻译完了以后
我们在上面念我们的稿子的时候
他们下面翻译就比较顺
所以我们都是自己写的
我的那个版本
流传比较广的版本
就是不愿意做牙医
想去文化馆上班
因为文化馆自由散漫
那么可以上班
可以迟到
也可以不去
是吗
就那个时代
现在不可能了
但是你刚才说的就是
是那个瞬间
我的感觉是这样的
就是那个瞬间的来到
其实它前面已经有很多铺垫了
如果你没有那种铺垫的话
它可能那个瞬间来了以后
你也就让它过了
你不会抓住它
莫言说的就是读了
很多很多的作品
就是有些作品你读完以后
你感觉是
真是写得很好
但是因为当我们都很年轻的时候
我们还没有开始写作的时候
有些作品
可能也就一两篇
或者是一两部
突然激发了你自己想写的愿望
它的那个作品可能会让你
我感觉到
我也能写作
就是有这样的一种
然后我就寄信就起来
然后就开始写作
但它肯定是有一个铺垫
因为我觉得
莫言刚才说是
读读的越多
肯定就越想写
但是另一个方面我觉得
那个有时候
你读读的少也是有可能想写
我们在那个特殊的年代的时候
我拿到一份外国小说
都是没头没尾的
前面少了十多页
后面又少了十多页
故事怎么开始你可以忽略
但是故事怎么结尾
你不知道很难受的
所以我印象中每次
我读完一个小说以后
我就在
在自己去想那个
不同的那个故事结尾的那个版本
想一个又一个
故事后面就少了十多页
你就是不知道故事是怎么结束的
人物的命运是什么样的
只能靠自己的想象去填补
我觉得在那么
在我还是个少年的时候
这种训练也是有很大帮助的
所以输多输少
都会给我们带来一个机会
一样的机会
就是突然想写了
那个瞬间就这样来到了
我有找一找余华老师这个瞬间
你有一篇散文
叫《十九年前的一次高考》
不知道你还记不记得
我记得
就给潘阳写了
最后那段话
我敢说很深
我给大家分享一下
后来有一天
我在看着大街的时候
心里突然涌上了一股悲凉
我想到自己将会一辈子
看着这条大街
我突然感到没有了前途
就是这一刻
我开始考虑起
自己的一生应该怎么办
我决定要改变自己的命运
于是我开始写小说了
我已经忘了自己这个结尾了
你也忘了
我还有点感动
我就是因为看到这个
我很感动
所以我觉得其实这个是
可能不管是什么年代的年轻人
他都有这样一个很迷茫的时候
我突然觉得
我的人生难道就这样了
我是不是应该改变一下自己
其实现在的
我觉得二三十岁的
很多的年轻人都是
面临这样一种困境
我站在人生的十字路口
我要留在大城市
我还是回老家
对吧
我是要一个稳定的工作
我还是出去闯闯
万一我闯出来
现在叫什么
叫奥德赛时期
对
我是当学会
你已经用了很多年了什么
刚刚发明了两三年
怎么可能有很多年
但是我知道稍微早一点
我们两万条留言里面
有很多人都问这个问题
奥德赛时期
帮我们问一下两位老师
现在我们就在这个奥德赛时期
他意思就是说
大概一般在二十到三十五岁之间
这一段人生
你可能面对很多变动
然后你产生一种迷茫
然后你产生一种漂泊感
他们把这一段时期
成为奥德赛时期
该怎么办
或者当年
你们俩是不是也有过这种时期
你们是怎么度过的
我们当然也有这种时期
刚才余华他讲
站在大街上说
看着来往的成年和人
产生那种对未来的迷茫
也还是深深的忧虑
难道就这样过一辈子吗
我觉得我这个时期
特别长了
从十六七岁
十五六岁
十三四岁在放牛的时候
可能就想到了
难道天天放牛吗
当时就想一定要出去
到外面去看更广大的世界
接触更多的人
学过更多的知识
后来到了棉花江工厂
接触了
反正一个县的
来自一个县的很多单位
很多村庄的
很多年轻人
包括青岛之青
然后在当兵
希望到部队去天南海北
我还确实非常感谢
在部队那几十年
第一部队让我读了很多的书
在顾县有学校
有老师
他们也都有些自然堂书
但是数量极其有限
到了部队
尤其我在图书馆里
兼传图书馆里员
就是眼界大开了
经过很多书就翻一翻
翻一翻
但是有点印象也没有印象要好
然后开始写作
开始发表小说以后
这种迷茫的状态
稍微好一点了
但是写作过程当中
依然有很多的困惑
你这样写是不是对
写着写着
你突然感觉它不会写了
又陷入到一种困境当中去
有千方百计的想办法突破
我写人的一辈子实际上没有说是
到了某一个阶段以后
就一劳永逸了
什么忧虑都没有了
天天养尊出忧就可以活下去了
即便到了我们这个年龄
余华也快70
余华也60多了
66了
我老叫他才刚50来岁
我自己都70多了
那依然还是感觉到有很多的困惑
尤其在写作过程当中
还是想千方百计的写出一点
跟自己过去的作品
不一样的东西来
通过阅读
是吧
通过体验生活
再通过一些别的方式
是吧
别的方式那些是
抖出去
到供广阔的地方去
看什么电影
在网络上接触各种各样的这种文化
总是不遗余率的
还是最终想达到一个目的
写出更好的作品
因为我们是以写作为职业的
所以希望年轻朋友们有这个阶段
也不要着急
总会过去
奥德修斯最终还是回到了他的家乡
进过海上漂泊了十年
经过了各种各样的苦难
但是最终还是回去了
实现了目标
回去以后一切都已经精飞细臂了
我的奥德赛时期要比莫言短
确实要比莫言短
因为莫言从放牛到去棉花厂的
又当兵
他的奥德赛时期也比我丰富
我的奥德赛时期
也就是亚裔那五年
这五年里边
我已经开始
后面的一两年
我已经开始写小说了
而且也发表了
但是并不是说是
当我们开始发表作品以后
甚至当我们成功以后
我们就没有奥德赛时期了
我觉得奥德赛时期
是一个人的一生的时期
就像莫言所说的
我们并不是说是
我们没有焦虑了
我们就没有迷茫了
我们在写作中
我们远远会面对一些困惑的时候
总是想跟我们自己写作的
昨天告别是吗
我们想去写新的东西
新的东西你又面临
一个新的一个时代的来临了
所以我觉得这个很正常
这不是一个过渡时期
这将是伴随我们一生的一个时期
无论是焦虑也好
迷茫也好
它往往是一种情绪
当这种情绪过去以后过去了
但是另一种新的情绪又来临了
可能还是以
你感觉到还是焦虑还是迷茫
面对的事物不一样了
所以你要做出调整
所以我觉得如何调整焦虑和迷茫
很重要
为什么呢
我突然想起来了
写作课里边收的关于墨延欢乐的那篇文章
就是随时我们共同的某亲
我想跟你们说
就是墨延是在
红高粱是哪一年
86年吧
86年发明
对
86年的时候
墨延已经是炉日中天了
就是在我们文学界
独则中间也一样
当年欢乐发表的时候
那可以说是整个文坛的围攻
批评
大家都很难接受
对
都接受不了这样的小说
因为它太挑战
我觉得还不是审美观念
主要是挑战他们的传统观念
所以他们对某亲的认知
就是跟我们不一样
不是说像一个人他成功以后
就没有挫折了
一样有
迷茫也好
焦虑也好
我们现在也依然会有迷茫
会有焦虑的时候
是吗
现在共多了
面对到来的时代
是吧
所以墨延刚这有一句话
是说的是很对的
生活是包罗万象的
各种各样的生活
都我们都要去学习
这就是人生
摆脱不了的人生
听完我的理解
就是人生其实
你坐山后面还有一座山
你以为你翻过去了
还有一座
所以你不要太在意
你有没有到山顶
你说的挺好
对
就这问题解决了
你以为翻过这个山头以后
以后就是一马平穿的
发现连绵不绝的山头
一山翻过一山拦
我觉得现在就有点理解了
因为我们还有一个读者
问一个问题
他就说
你们两位都写了
这么快致人口的作品了
得了国内国际的大奖
全得完了
这个年纪了
为什么还继续写
你们还有新的问题
还有新的挑战
还想继续做
所以你们还会继续写
是这样吗
对
我们当然要继续写
关键是一个最重要的原因
这是我们还具有了继续写的能力
我们拥有了继续学习的能力
很有创作的比较强烈的激情
这个也很重要
激情很重要
还是感觉的
不写会难受
能写出来
跟自己过去的作品有区别的作品
头脑伤出了文学素材库里
还有一些素材
还挺宝贵的
尤其是新的生活普面而来
尤其是AI时代
各种可能性
现在就只有我们想不到的
没有人干不到
做不到的了
在这样一种情况下
一方面是焦虑困惑
一方面又是坚信
自己心里边这些东西不能放弃
在矛盾斗中过程当中
恰好产生作品的突然
就接着沐阳老师提着AI
咱聊一会 AI和写作的这个事情
对吧
现在我觉得现在有两种声音
有一种人说AI时代到了
文科生淘汰了
因为现在AI就可以写作
很多人就直接用AI写一些它需要的东西
还有一种声音说
AI时代文科生的时代来了
对吧
因为AI它可能可以干很多工具型的事
但是文科生
它有自己的创意
它有审美
这种能力好像在这个时代更凸显了
我不知道两位老师觉得
这两种声音你们觉得更倾向哪个
不管一个他怎么想
我是认为我们写作这个行业
还是起码短时间内是不可代替的
尤其是具有个性的原创性的文学作品
因为AI它现在在牛
是吧
它也是建立在前人写作的
重国的基础上
包括我们的小说
也可能被喂到AI的胃里肚子里去了
它会通过它那个巨大的算力
是吧
就把它已经掌握的调料重新组合
如果没有源源不断的新的食物喂给它
它水平也就停止不前了
我们就是给它提供它没有吃过的食物和原料的
所以我觉得还是不可代替的
当然你如果作为一种辅助手段
利用它来写一些原创性不太强的
但是技术要求比较高的作品
那个可能也是确实它显示出很大的优越性
比如你让它写一首格律诗词
它肯定写得很快
起码它在技术上不会犯错误
前年你们杭州的一个特别有名的一个庙语
林隐寺
建庙是1300周年
当时它长老了
它那个当家的大合成
就通过我的朋友找到
我希望我能写一个副
没有AI的时候
我说我可以试一试
有了AI的话
我得写这种文章
AI比我写的肯定要好
那即便我不用AI
我写了写的也不错
那别人一看还是会说
这是AI写的是吧
对
所以我说也没有必要我来写这种骗体文
要求对账
要求评阁
过了几天我突发灵感
我说那我索性试一下
不过豆包豆包有这么一件事
你给我写一篇副
一千多左右
他给我说了半天
分析我要怎么写
我说你快写吧
大概也就是几分钟的时间出来了
确实是磁套华丽
对账公正
真是在技术上挑不出毛病了
但是没有思想
后来有一次我跟谁
李靖泽聊天聊到这个问题
我说他没有思想
李靖泽说那不愿意谈怨你
你给他一个思想
他就会给你演艺的很好
回去我真试了一下
我说根据以前你给我写这个文章
加上这样一种思想
庙语不是市场
我们进庙不得去感激
试试不得交易
我到了庙来去捐了一千块钱
你不能跟佛祖去讨价还价
确实是很好了
一下有了思想了
到目前为止的AI的情况确实是如此
就是我们喂给他什么
他就有什么
但当我们不再喂给他了
他可能就没有了
但是智能体AI会不会不是这样
他会自己创造
我们大家当然一方面是很惊讶
人工智能一下子变得这么聪明了
因为他以前还是蛮笨的说实话
但是并没有认为
他可以替代这个替代那个
但是随着这几年
一年一年的新的AI的那些
起来将来会走到哪一步
其实我们是不知道的
反正我看了一下
那个我忘了是国外哪个报纸
说是50个行业被AI取代的
我不知道你看过那个没有
作家整个行业大概排在20多位
所以为什么我们很心安
因为我们得穿加前面20多个追悼会以后
才能到我们的追悼会
那个时候我们就知道
应该是穿什么衣服的
这个我肯定是同意
我觉得莫言说得非常对的一点
就是在AI面前
原创越强大的人
肯定存活的几率越大
其实我看有的人在逃
在那个头头是到的
讲解这个世界民族
说对
讲得特别好
我都跟着看
我就是特别省事的一种方式
了解我没读过这些
长篇小说的主要内容和思想
但是也说AI生成的呀
这个当然它就是
实际上还是有它的一定的
积极的作用
但大部分这种心灵
鸡汤一类的东西
确实是有害无忧
刚才莫言老师说
您居然也会看那个
就是几分钟看完一篇名称
您居然也会看这种的视频
我这个毛病刚染上两年
两年就很长了
两年已经感觉到势力在下降
因为中常半夜睡醒了以后
不可控制的手都摸到手机
摸过来看一段视频
这个玩意这个手机
而且你看了什么以后
它老跟你同一所号
我在老看一萌山赶大吉的时候
我现在对一萌山的大吉
了解的比我们村的吉还清楚
哪个地方卖什么的
还有那些村里面的人
一萌山费钱好像是一个
赶老太的一个小剧组
大概一个男的可能是40来岁
他扮演这个老太太
然后他一个小小的剧组
大概有七八个人
今天演这个明天演那个
完全他是一个专业的小戏般的
我的发言是吧
像这样的一种
就在网络上用这样的方式
就变成一个职业化的一个东西
网络小集团
现在特别多这样的
我没想到您会看那个
几分钟看完世界明珠
我以为就是
这个讲述
讲述是不会看这个
我看的不是几分钟
讲一个是电影
大概20年开始
我就一直在看那个
一晚上看七八部电影
都是十来分钟就一部电影讲完了
但后来影响我观音体验了
当我在看一部电影的时候
就是有一种感觉就是
这部电影好像看过
好像又没看过
就是你故事情节是知道的
但是那个电影里边的
那些最精华的部分忽略的
他给你讲的只是一个梗概
其实小说也好
电影也好